hey everybody welcome back to politics
today I want to showcase three parks
made by Studio kV and just for a bit of
context I don't necessarily want to make
my channel into a showcase channel of
this game but studio K V is somebody
I've been following on YouTube for a
long time and honestly whenever I
started recording a new video of one of
the scenarios of the campaign mode of
this game I always checked out his
videos on the game just for inspiration
and ideas
he makes absolutely amazing videos and
while his main language is Korean he
does always add English annotations so
it's just really interesting to learn
from how he plays this game and for me
personally it's also been really fun to
see how he completes some of the
scenarios which I've built just because
his way of taking this game and creating
new scenery pieces and sort of taking
them in in new ways is really cool now I
don't want to just make this in
advertisements but by all means please
subscribe to his channel I'll link it
down in the description because his
stuff is absolutely beautiful and I'm
gonna try and use this video as proof of
this now a little bit more context the
reason why I'm actually showing off
three parks in this video rather than
taking one park and looking at it's in a
sort of in-depth review is because I
originally planned to make a showcase of
K V land a while ago but I never really
got around to it and today the new DLC
for Park Tech is coming out in fact it's
the first DLC
it's called taste of adventure and it
features a new campaign new rides a host
of really cool unique features and also
two new scenery themes and studio K V
made a trailer for the DLC featuring two
parks which he specifically built to
show off these themes so in this video I
want to showcase these two parks along
with a brief look into K V land which is
sort of main park that he's built
recently on his YouTube channel although
now he's gone on to make some other
things like smaller dioramas which are
also really interesting but I think K V
land is probably his big
and most ambitious project so something
really interesting to look into as well
now kV already made a really good video
outlining the different features of the
DLC I'll link that down in the
description as well if you're curious to
see what the game is going to feature in
this new DLC but he didn't really give
much of an in-depth look into these
newly built parks so I would like to dig
into these and see what kind of tricks
he's done especially given the fact that
all of the scenery is just now coming
out today and he already seems to have
mastered it so it'll hopefully be a bit
of a lesson for all of us so this map
that I'm looking at right now is Candy
Land and it showcases the new candy land
theme in the game and as you can see
everything is quite bright even the
water is now pink which is one of the
features of the DLC is that you can now
color water although I also have to say
along with the DLC is a free updates of
the game and I believe the colouring of
water is available for free as well but
you're gonna have to check out
architect's website for more detailed
information I'll put that down in the
description as well but anyway moving on
everything in this park is absolutely
pastel colored one of my favorite things
that sort of stuck out to me when I
started looking at this is the amazing
giant table set which he made here
showcasing some of the new candy pieces
that we have and there is really a very
wide variety in these if you go into the
scenery and I turn off everything except
the candy theme and if you go to props
there's about 24 candy-themed props that
you can use and I think that the best
way to sort of combine them is to use
these large cake layers and build up
different cakes with it and then you
have this large assortment of things
that you can place on top of this and he
used some stuff of that very creatively
throughout this build as you'll see but
this is probably my favorite use of it's
just this giant table set made out of
some really unique pieces like the
candle over here for instance being made
out of pillar pieces and then having the
giraffe statue in the middle of the cake
but
other than that it's really just using
these new candy pieces I also really
just love the chyann chair something to
also know it is the licorice over here
which is really a fence which you can
recolor in pretty much any color you
want to provide some candy themed fences
around your paths this is the clockwork
which is a new ride which I believe is
based on its Emperor right in real life
but I'm not entirely sure but it's a
very recent addition actually in terms
of the flat right roster in real life as
well but it's this really cool right
where you have different spinning arms
that kind of look like they're gonna
intercept each other but really they
don't because mechanically they they
really can't but yeah moving on from
that one of my favorite parts also about
this build is the entrance building and
I'm calling it an entrance building
because technically if you turn off all
of this scenery this is where the people
are coming from but it's really the main
weanie of the park if you were the sort
of disney castle like addition with also
the the flagship attraction which is the
spinning coaster here going all around
it and what i thought was really cool
about this build in particular is the
way that he used the whipped cream piece
which is from the candy set as sort of
clouds around the castle and also used
different pieces of candies to top off
the spires of the building which i
thought is really cool and now i'm
probably gonna have to talk about this
coaster for a bit because this is a new
coaster type and while it's similar to
the spinning coaster that's already in
the game this one's much more intense
it's based on the real-life neck
spinning coaster at least that's as far
as I can gather like time traveller for
instance in Silver Dollar City is very
similar to this so it has a launch
section actually you can launch this
thing so if I turn off this view here we
go
then you can see a launch section right
inside or right next to the building
here actually and you can also go upside
down with it so you can make some really
interest
with that now moving on from there is
something which I also found really
interesting is the new gingerbread
pieces which are I suppose a bit
Christmassy as well I think you can
probably kind of combine that with a
sort of winter theme as well but they're
basically just standard gingerbread
pieces I can probably take a look that's
them in the scenery menu here you just
get a bunch of walls a roof and certain
detailing to make an icing based
gingerbread house and I thought it made
some interesting combinations with these
pieces as well some interesting colors
of or interesting choices of colors
because as you can see each of these
gingerbread houses even though they use
the same gingerbread pieces they all
have a different kind of color scheme
and personally color schemes I think are
one of the strongest points of Katies
builds he always manages to find a
different color scheme for every
building and somehow makes them fit
together and in this Park especially
there's really creative use of color I
think whether it's recoloring these
trees to make them look like candy trees
this is really just a regular sort of
green Bobbie trees usually these are
actually one of my favorite trees in the
game I'm not entirely sure yeah there we
go the blobby tree but even the other
ones pretty much anything is a corner
ball in the foliage section of this game
so you can actually play a lot with that
and it's something that honestly I think
I have to do a bit more because I'm kind
of uncreated when it comes to recoloring
foliage to kind of make new things but
Cavey always does it really well and
something which I also like is the new
rock pieces so you can see some of the
old rocks that have always been in the
game here but the adventure theme also
gave us some new rock pieces with gems
on it which are really cool and they
kind of combine really well with the old
rock pieces as well which is nice and
speaking of recolored foliage he also
used the yucca plants from the adventure
theme and kind of recall it them to
provide some very colorful ground
shrubbery which I thought was an
interesting
sort of variation as well something
which I tended to forget all the time is
that many of these adventure pieces are
completely recolor bow even if you think
that they're not going to be so the
monster of lands for instance can also
just be recolored to make it purple so I
mean this is especially useful if you're
trying to make something kind of
unrealistic and playful like the candy
land theme here but it could even be
useful in a real-life situation or in a
sort of realistic situation I should say
if you're going for a bit more variation
in your foliage colors I don't know
that's a point of which personally I
think I should take for myself and yeah
that is basically as much as I guess I
could say about this build oh one of my
other things I really like about this is
just the different hues of the path work
you can really see a sort of subtle
transition from different blues and
purples and pink shades across the path
work which this looks really cool and it
doesn't even take that much effort if
you zoom in you can kind of see the
subtle changes from one shade to another
but as soon as you zoom out and you get
the whole picture you can just see the
path kind of subtly changing as you're
going from one area to the next anyway
that's about all I wanted to say about
the candy land theme now let's move on
to the adventure map that Cavey made
because it's also really interesting and
it showcases some of my favorite new
rides and this DLC and here we go here's
the adventure themed map and as you can
see it's very different and largely
based on sort of South and Central
American Mayan architecture Inca
architecture these kinds of things it's
it's to me always felt very Indiana
Jones II if you go to Disney parks and
look at the Indiana Jones rights kind of
that sort of adventure theme because
obviously adventure is quite a broad
theme but this is where really a lot of
the architectural and prop elements are
taken from and if you look at the kind
of wall sets which I've got here
it's all very much this subtle brick
texture with different detailing on it
and different pieces that you can
combine to create these large pyramids
which you see here now there are also
some interesting props which some of
these were honestly added while Katie
was still working on these parks so not
everything is featured in these parks
not even every ride is featured in this
parks some of the new roller coasters
and rides are missing from it but this
also kind of means that even for me some
of these pieces are very new even if
I've been updated with you know the
pieces that are being added for these
DLCs while they're being added a lot of
this stuff was really just added a few
weeks leading up to the release of the
DLC so it's kind of new for me sometimes
as well and especially the foliage
though I think is really cool this was
definitely some of the earliest stuff
that I remember being added of the
Adventure theme but with just these few
extra tropical pieces and especially
these fine pieces I think there's a lot
more variation that you can add in your
foliage if you combine them with you
know the existing trees and palm trees
that were already in the game that kind
of go with the adventure theme as well
especially given the fact that to be
honest the foliage choice in the
original game was a bit limited just the
fact that you get this extra crunch
already to play with I think helps out a
lot in creating variety and complexity
in your foliage anyway to actually talk
about the map which Katie made here I
think its overall just a good showcase
of what you can build with the new
building pieces so you can really see
this sort of Inca Aztec Mayan kind of
architecture here and especially on the
wooden coaster I think it was used
really creatively and want to catch a
POV actually of this one sometime soon
because I really like this one but yeah
we'll get to that in a second first I
wanted to showcase some of the newer
rides which I really like so you have
the river rapids and something that I
thought was absolutely amazing about
these things is that you can actually
change the width of the track I'm not
entirely sure if you should call it a
track but then I'm not sure what else to
call it but you can make it as as wide
as you want within a certain margin
which I believe this is the widest who
can go but within this and this you can
make it just about as wide as you want
and then you have these different sort
of standard pieces to play with now the
river rapids is of course is staple of
theme park games and they always kind of
play out the same but in this case I
think it's quite a bit more flexible
because you have this sort of with
changing - whenever you want it to be
and as you can see pieces like the
waterfall pieces also conform to
whatever curve you're doing so the
waterfalls can be straight or they can
be an S Pen or a curve depending on
whatever you want to do they can be on
one side or on the other side of the
track or even on both sides but one of
my favorite additions here is these new
bumpers which you can add into the track
they automatically change to the right
rotation depending on which side of the
track their ads and they can be used to
sort of get the rafts out of a sticky
situation where they get stuck anywhere
but they're just such a staple on real
life Rapids that I never really saw
integrated in a theme park game like
this that I think it's really cool to
see them maybe I should just close this
right get the people off it so you can
kind of see how it works you can really
just grab one of these and place them
anywhere once so I thought that was
really cool I never really imagined you
know a building system that works more
like just object placements working
within the track builder for the rapids
now scenery wise there isn't that much
else that I want to talk about but I
also want to point out the new car ride
which is kind of like a safari adventure
ride which here has been worked out
really beautifully within these giants
buildings and I really like the
interaction here between the car ride
and the drop tower here it's this really
cool sort of complex with different you
know tracks of the car ride weaving into
each other and then you've got these
paths which kind of lead up to the drop
tower
I just always really liked seeing this
sort of complexity and different layers
of different
and stuff you know kind of overlapping
each other I don't know that's always
something that I try to do as much as
possible in my scenario builds but
sometimes it's really difficult to pull
it off but I think this part of the map
specifically pulls it off really well
and what I really like about the Safari
ride in particular is that it has a very
similar thing to the bumpers of the
river rabbits so if I just close this
for a second and trying to edit it you
might have noticed that there are these
small and slightly larger bumps on the
track and they work in a very similar
way you can just drag a bump and drag it
to anywhere on the track that you want
and make any combination of bumps that
you want and you can really you can get
the car to do some crazy bumpy movements
with this or just do it like if you did
here and just have a bump here and there
so you add a bit to the thrill of the
right even if it's just a calm family
right that's more focused on a sort of
dark ride you know scenery perspective
but um yeah that is just about it now
it's time to move on to the wooden
coaster and let's see if we can actually
catch this going around all right
there we go now I think kV was inspired
by sort of very thematic wooden coasters
in real life the sort of a route
shabanam and see Philippe Copenhagen for
instance these old winning posters would
be a lot of scenery around them and
layouts I kind of go back and forth but
in this case this wooden coaster in the
game which is a new type is the inverted
wooden coaster and as you've already
told it can go upside down in well a
bunch of sort of standard inversions
that you might already know like cork
screws and loops and then whatever
twists you can come up with and it's
actually based I believe on the gravity
group inverting coasters in real life
partly at least the cars look like this
very much and
if you build a corkscrew though it looks
very much like the new GCI
poster concepts which if you seen my
planet coaster is your gardens videos
where I try to make an inverting GC I
wouldn't coaster they very much resemble
this and this is a new type of wooden
coaster by GTI which is not actually
built yet in real life it's still only
shown off the I am Park invention but
it's a really cool coaster type and I
was personally really excited to see
this make its way into the game I have
to say just to address a bunch of
comments about our MCS
as far as I'm aware the devs also want
to add our MCS into the game but it's
really difficult to do this support wise
so for now for inverting wooden coasters
this is the more feasible option and I
can't make any promises or statements
about other kind of coaster types that
may or may not be added into the game in
the future but I'm really glad that this
one's been added anyway because it's a
really cool sort of way to add variety
and more thrills on the standard wooden
coaster speaking of which I think the
DLC really sort of has this as an
overarching theme to take coasters that
we already know sort of have but add new
more modern and thrilling editions of it
so we've got the launched inverting
spinning coaster the inverting wooden
coaster here and then two other coaster
types that I might as well show off
another edition is the swinging coaster
which is like a wild mouse but it rocks
from side to side and then the vertical
spinning coaster which is like the
real-life 40 coaster where the seats can
freely flip upside down which is also
really cool anyway back to cavies Park
some other pointers that I think he did
really well and that honestly I can
learn a bit from as well is just the
sheer variety of foliage you can really
see the mixture of new adventure foliage
along with some of the old palm trees
and bushes that we already had to make
this very jungle
esque foliage around this whole area I
really like the addition of the basalt
rocks
everywhere which are a new scenery piece
which you can find in props to add these
kind of volcanic rock pieces which is a
really cool touch and just overall the
way that he used the standard stone
pieces to make the the basic shapes of
all the buildings and then added all
kinds of details like these yellow and
blue decorations over here and a lot of
these other buildings as well I thought
that was just a really neat way of using
this theme for me personally
whenever I'm subjected to a new theme in
a game like this it's always a bit of a
struggle to figure out you know how you
can use these pieces exactly but I think
cavies builds kind of showed off how you
can use these pieces and kind of give a
baseline to take some inspiration from
and to sort of base your own build on so
honestly I kind of wish then I was able
to see these parks before I started on
the campaign because they give some
really cool ideas about what you can do
with the theme but not much I can change
about that in hindsight speaking of
which I haven't even said this in any
official capacity I suppose but I've
worked on the campaign for the new DLC
as well so if you're curious about that
I'll definitely show those off on
youtube at some point in the future
anyway I'm getting too off-topic it's
time to move over to the topic of this
video and why I wanted to make this
video in the first place
and focusing a bit more on Cavey himself
and why I like his stuff so much it's
time to look at KP land all right now it
is finally time to take a brief look
into K V land and I just realized why
I'm not a showcase youtuber because I
keep going off topic but I'm gonna try
to stay on topic as much as I can here
and just give you a brief overview of
the park now before I get into this
apologies for the mediocre frame rates I
really can't get this to run better on
my slow computer and keep in mind this
is really a huge park with a lot of
stuff in it so there's quite a bit to
explore but I've noticed that as long as
i zoom in a little bit the frame rate is
decent enough
and come think of it I guess I'm not as
terrible of a position because I
remember that coaster be did send me his
bike because he couldn't get a decent
framerate at all but here we go I'm
getting off topic again so starting off
I'm just gonna start off with what kV
started off in his series with so I'm
gonna try to follow a bit of a
chronological path with this video so we
have a large highway going here with the
this place where all of the supplies
would be dropped off and there's a giant
backstage area for the park here with
these stuff things from a gameplay
perspective but then also this really
cool storage of spare roller coaster
track and scenery pieces and coaster
cars which i think is really awesome
because that's definitely the kind of
place that you could realistically see
in real life you know these locations
where shipments get dropped off and
where if there's gonna be a new roller
coaster being built or there's some
spare Trek or whatever you could always
have some stuff just lying around but
yeah from there we go into the entrance
of the carpark which is pretty much just
a car park kind of a standard fare I
guess but personally I'm really bad at
making car parks so I really respects
how well organized and laid out this car
park is even if it is quite a small one
and I especially like the whole bus
section here we're right in front of the
entrance quite public transit oriented
we have a giant bus depot which is super
nice and I really love the design also
of the whole canopy in front of it as
well and there's even a custom bus which
looks really cool which if you zoom in
you can tell is really just a bunch of
walls and detailing makes it look like
an actual bus but it works super well in
this situation so I don't know I really
appreciate that but yeah going from
there we get the actual entrance of the
park API ins Plaza with a very large
almost castle like building which is
what kV started off the park with and
next to that we have a very similar sort
of building which looks very fancy from
the inside but then on the other side
it's really just a sort of construe
in place and you can tell that just like
real life folks will often do this whole
facade is really nothing more than just
a facade and not an actual building but
yeah going from the entrance which is
this giant gate here we have a large
area with a lot of parts which I think
makes a lot of sense this is the kind of
area I think you'll see at the start of
the park you know there's a lot of
people around here you need all of that
space some of the small things that
really struck my eye here is the the way
that he used different paths colors to
make these subtle differences in the
asphalt or concrete flooring which
you'll often see in real-life parks
especially if they have the paths which
are made out of different slabs of
concrete material you really see these
sort of minor differences in the
textures so I really like this sort of a
subtle approach to different paths
textures and next to that a nice little
teacups with a tent-like structure which
I've never personally tried with the
cables like this but it's something that
I should probably try in some point in
the future if not just with a different
design but I really like the simplicity
of this flat right skin now the sort of
first main attraction even if it's just
a very simple coaster is rolling Zets
or z depending on whether you're an
American or British person right here
which is based on rolling X in Korea I
actually didn't know about rolling X
before kV introduced it in his series I
only knew Everland from the T Express
and the the Eco sports which are both
very famous coasters in the
roller-coaster community but the rolling
X is apparently just a simple
aerodynamics corkscrew coaster and so
this is the kind of layouts that kV
built here only thing to note I suppose
about this layout is that the corkscrews
go opposite directions which in real
life they're both in the same direction
but given the fact that we don't have
diagonal corkscrews that work out really
well with a layout like this I
understand that kV had to change the
direction of one of the corkscrews but
overall I think the layout looks really
cool
I really like the station coming into
this sort of main plaza of the of the
park and then of course a transfer track
as well with a little roof over it which
is really nice and even an entrance for
employees and this is the kind of insane
detail to try and make this bike feel a
bit more real and feel a bit more
realistic just like all of the clutter
around the entrance that I really like
about this park now moving on a little
bit from there to the rights as Katie
did in his original series I suppose is
a splash battle which honestly I had
never tried this flash pencil in Park
tech before I saw this and personally I
was so surprised to see these ring
targets everywhere and see that people
really aiming for this I had no idea
that the splash battle in poiitics
worked this way and that you can just
put these ring targets wherever you want
but it's really cool definitely
something I might try later on because
I'm not much of a splash battle person
but if it's done like this it's really
quite an interesting and interactive
ride now I've heard Katie's say that
this was based on some sort of Lego set
and have to be honest I don't know much
about Lego so I don't really recognize
it from anything but I do like the
station filming loss with these very
bright contrasting colors and it
slightly asymmetrical design like this
very fortress-like and very pirate like
as the rest of this area in general
turns out to be as well as you're moving
into the log flume here which is also
pirate themed and then finally you have
a large pirate ship in the middle of
this and again I just really like the
way that everything interacts here
everything kind of being put on top of
each other and interacting with
different parts of the park having
locklear interact with the pots and vice
versa in this way it just looks really
cool and it's a really nice way to make
right feel a bit more interconnected I
also like the transition here from a
very dark past the light paths here
maybe I should try to transition my
paths a bit more as well because the
fact that you can recolor anything to
anything that you
makes the game very flexible and this is
something which I should probably use a
nice a bit more anyway moving on from
that we have here a client area with
Greek Gardens and this is really just
mostly fancy there aren't many right
here we have the setup of the carousel
in this large sort of symmetrical
geometric garden and then a giant
station for the monorail which goes
around the entire park so it's a bit
like a Disney park in that sense which
was probably also a lot of the
inspiration you know this park is very
similar to these kinds of very heavily
themed parks that might not per se be
planned beforehand like this neat but at
the same time have a very large budget
and are able to make these large
immersive areas and yeah moving on from
that is honestly what I just find
probably the most beautiful area in the
park this is one area which personally I
really love even if it's not very exact
in its teaming this is the Far Eastern
shangri-la area of the park and it's
it's a bit funny because I originally
expected this to be a purely Korean
style build but as kv himself said it's
a bit difficult to distinguish between
different Asian roofs or different Asian
architectural styles of Japanese Chinese
and Korean because they all come from
the same roots in the far distant
history nowadays they're obviously quite
different and they each have very
different detailing and compositions etc
but when you're just doing a sort of
overall basic Asian style in quite fact
it can be quite generic and quite
nonspecific but regardless of that I
really love the setup of the scenery
piece here just this whole build with
the waterfalls and these giant buildings
next to them it has a lot of depth to it
and I almost wish I could cut out this
section and just make it a little
diorama like some of his recent videos
because it just works so well on its own
and
I don't know there's not there's not
even much that I could say about it some
of the things which I guess I could
point out is that he used some of the
fantasy walls which are curving and kind
of look like an Asian roof to make these
pointy Asian roofs and then on the sides
it's really just a combination of
different roof corners to make the
pointed bits at the end of the roof of
course it doesn't look exactly like it
would in real life but I think within
Park effect it's as much of an
approximation as you can do without
resorting to a lot of custom-made assets
and mods speaking of which I should also
say this park uses moths
but it's very different from coaster
based Busch Gardens I think in a sense
that the mod use is very very limited
I'm not exactly sure how many months
this this map uses but I think it's ten
or less and it's really just kind of
sprinkled here and there and it's mostly
related to rollercoasters and other sort
of practical theme park things like that
the road pieces for instance are a mod
he used mods to create the separate
track pieces and catwalks for the
coasters but when it comes to the
scenery most of it is just completely
in-game and vanilla so this whole build
you could technically just build with
the vanilla build of the game anyway I
should probably talk about this coaster
for a bit because this is personally I
think my favorite coaster let's actually
give it a right quick you see it going
now ascension and apparently it also has
a Korean name that I'm not going to be
able to read or pronounce so I'm just
gonna refer to it as ascension and it's
it's a hyper coaster with a launched
lift oil which is really interesting
based on the the in-game hyper coast
which is based on the intamin real-life
hyper coaster and it sort of does a very
standard out-and-back layouts originally
it had a slightly different layout which
was apparently a bit more simple but now
it has this sort of tangle at the the
end of the layout before it makes its
way back to the station with a bunch of
airtime Hills
and yeah I just really like this layouts
but most of all I love the the
interaction that it has with the station
area and once you come back you have
this whole intricate structure with the
break ones up here and then if I turn
off the scenery view for a second here
Oh Oh God there we go now you can see
that in reality it just kind of loops
down here and then comes back but you
know he could have just gone into the
lift hill straight away of course but I
really like that it just goes down here
has a bit of interaction with the
fountain with the small foam pond here
and yeah it's just a nice twist on what
would otherwise this be a very standard
layout and of course something that I
also like is the sign that he added
later because this is really one of the
two major coasters in the park and one
of the things that's supposed to draw in
guests so it has a very fancy sign on
the little with also a custom support
structure so he used some of the tower
pieces to make these custom supports and
finally added some catwalks which is
custom scenery so that's not from the
vanilla game but it just added some
catwalks to go down here although my
roller coaster enthusiasts sensibilities
would kind of like to protest this idea
because at the end of the day you can
really just walk down here on the
catwalk as well that's kind of the idea
of a catwalk but I I'm sorry I have to
appreciate the structure of it anyway
moving on from there we have the science
fiction themed area and this area is
probably the most intricate and detailed
area in the park perhaps not in terms of
the piece count but definitely in terms
of how much there is to look at there's
so much stuff overlapping each other
here that it's difficult to even see
where to start personally this always
reminded me of some old flux trans bones
in rollerCoaster Tycoon 2 and well it
goes to Tycoon 3
he always did some very similar stuff
like this it was always a sci-fi themed
sort of industrial desolates cyberpunk
style
area and I mean I totally mean that as a
compliment the Flex sponsors roller
coaster going to that was really cool
now this area features one roller
coaster in my build of the game but when
Katie showed off the vertical spinning
coaster in the trailer for Pike tech he
actually put it down here in this area
so you can't see the vertical spinning
coaster here but it would have been
there but we do have the conveyor
Express which is a really creative way
to use the wild mouse coaster to make
this sort of conveyor belt like roller
coaster it has a bunch of really long
straight sections which I guess from a
coaster perspective don't really make
that much sense but from a themed
perspective it's really cool and it's
really well immersed into this general
sci-fi theme the same goes for the
launched drop tower here which has a
really cool structure around it as well
and yeah just the the overall area of
the sci-fi theme is really hard to take
in if you do not if you're zoomed out
like this so just a bunch of other
structures that I want to check out
he used recolored rocks to make sort of
glowing rock structures which I thought
are super interesting and then there is
this machine that seems the kind of mine
it Out's
that also interacts with the monorail so
there's that extra layer of scenery
interaction there giant building here
for the monorail station which is a bit
obscured by the tower here we go
everything very intricate and lots of
different elements interacting with each
other I for some reason really like the
coloring on this whole Emory that just
this soda you know yellow color and then
no other colors with maybe just a few
accents here and there but mostly just
yellow and gray scales it works out
really well to make this whole kind of
messy area in terms of structure seeing
fits together really well in terms of
the colors and yeah moving on from there
if we go to the entrance of this whole
area there's a there's a really cool
structure down here as well which I
believe yeah
we go features another station for the
unique sort of inland monorail which
goes around there and sort of makes were
almost a kind of public transportation
system within this area with local and
regional trains which it's it's kind of
cool to see that sort of thing I'm quite
the public transportation nerd and this
is really taking me back to urban
monorail systems anyway not to dwell not
to dwell on that for too long
moving back down for an area which I
totally forgot about earlier so I'm
sorry I'm actually gonna have to go back
here for a second this is the old
British area and it has a coaster which
is very obviously inspired by oblivion
in Alton Towers a simple drop tower with
a vertical or a simple vertical drop
coaster with a drop straight underground
surrounded by paths and after that you
just curve it to do a quick spiral
around the spiral a slide here and then
you get back into this station so it's a
very simple right it's a very simple
area which he made in just one episode
if I remember correctly but I really
liked it as a touch to sort of fill in
the rest of the park and it transitions
quite well with some of the surrounding
areas as well it's always very difficult
to figure out a way to transition
between different areas so here for
instance it's a large gates building for
the sci-fi area it's this building with
the monorail station and the toilets in
it and this British area here just fills
in the spaces between it's quite well
and then moving from there we get what
in terms of scenery is also one of my
favorite areas the Alpine area and this
is honestly an area that I ended up
taking quite a bit of inspiration from
if not just for my scenario playthroughs
because I really like the approach to
colors and textures and different items
in this in this area and I think it
shows off cavies play style very well so
we have a large entrance building here
and then an Alpine village with a bunch
of buildings and
different squares here and I really like
the way that he used different path
textures again with the slightly
different colors everywhere but then
also some divisions between different
types of bricks leading to different
places here so it's a bit more
interesting than just having the same
path texture everywhere and something
which heavy really tends to do is use
different pieces in the game to sort of
create his own textures so he usually
puts different items into walls to make
small bricks and he does it so well for
some of these buildings in this area so
here for instance you can see the
cornerstones the brick cornerstones
which are a scenery piece in the game
over here to make bricks but then also
he uses for instance I believe this is a
chimney piece and some other small
pieces I'm not even sure which piece
this is exactly okay so that's just a
border arch see how some of these are on
grid some of these are off grid and it
just kind of mixes them together to make
an overall quite organic sort of stucco
wall with just a few bricks popping out
here and there to create a brick texture
and this is really cool and it tends to
do it a lot on the Alpine theme and it
shows really well here and this area
also has one of the sort of flagship
rise of the park the giant wooden
coaster mount wave and it definitely
looked like a wave this thing has always
reminded me of Haggai in Nagashima span
and in Japan with its huge structure and
very big white supports and actually the
support structure is extra large because
this cave he ended up adding a lot of
custom supports to it to make it a bit
more strong and to make it seem a bit
more stable I suppose because in the
game when you start building diagonal
you end up getting very few supports and
especially if you were sort of
overlapping earlier parts of the track
they start disappearing very quickly so
yeah with these supports and the blue
track it looks very similar to Haku gay
and very similar to a wave sort of
crashing up until the shore of a
mountain
or something like that so yeah I really
like this layout as well something to
also note is just the use of mountains
around the entire park to basically make
it feel like there's this large Mountain
Valley on the side here which I suppose
is also inspired by ever land in Korea
which is similarly built into the
mountain and so you have these two
flagship coasters kind of towering over
the park on top of the hills very
similar to how to express and well in
the past I suppose egos for tourists do
it in Everland in Korea I think it's
just also interesting how a lot of
people end up taking the inspiration
from very local sources like that given
that I've always taken a lot of my
inspiration from European parks even
when it comes to different things anyway
that'll do it for cave eel and I hope
you guys were as inspired by this build
as I've been throughout the last couple
of months trying to stay updated with
what Cavey has been building and trying
to take some inspiration from it because
honestly he makes some really great
stuff and also a lot of videos because
this barely scratches the surface of
what caving is made so if you want to
see more parka text videos and perhaps
even some playthroughs of the campaign
of the next DLC because as far as I've
heard he's gonna be also making some
videos of that definitely subscribe to
studio Cavey and yeah stay up-to-date to
all of his videos I'm not even gonna try
to advertise myself here because I don't
think I've reached anywhere near this
level on sand box parka text although
speaking of that before I close I always
get a lot of questions if I'm gonna play
parka tech in sandbox and while I purrs
while I've responded to a lot of the
comments and you think it's probably
good to also address this in a video I
do want to play parka tech sandbox at
some point but I also want to finish the
campaign before I get there and right
now I'm very stuck on Hickory Hills and
trying to get over it but once the whole
campaign is done and by that I mean the
base game campaign but I also want to
play the DLC campaign I'd love to try
something sandbox Bay
especially with all the mods and assets
which are coming out on this Steam
Workshop so yeah I'd like to thank you
guys for watching and I hope to see you
in the next box text video bye guys